want to be propelled out of water at
high speed then flyboarding might be for
you
Marco amico is a huge fan he was one of
the first to offer courses in the new
sport in teen yala on Lake Garda when
he's using the water jet powered choose
the extreme sportsman attracts lots of
attention he's fascinated by the
sensation mmse keep the old and defended
in the info 25 meters up in the air
hovering there thanks to the pressure
under your feet you feel strange how you
feel like Superman oh man my fifty I
thank you feel free it's like a toy for
men who've never grown up so I can use
today Marco amico is conducting
so-called superhero training for
beginners Austrian Christian demo from
Innsbruck has signed up for the course
the flyboarding instructor explains the
basic techniques on dry land
so if I tip for what I can hold myself
up with the supports within Hank do some
constant selfish and of course you can
stabilize yourself with the hand jazz
but if you can't then you can always
push the hand jet back to the side meet
Dean and dive headfirst into the water
like a dolphin orenstein Vita and then
rise out of the water like a dolphin to
in Vaasa even in Syria doesn't sound
that easy after a brief introduction
plus chandimal takes a leap into cold
water I'm very excited I've got no idea
what it will be like but I'll take it as
it comes doesn't mean I left well he
doesn't exactly look like Superman at
first but flying is an art after all
flyboarding shot to fame after a video
showing experts performing incredible
stunts went viral the sport was invented
by a Frenchman back in 2011 the first
World Championships took place in the
qatari capital Doha last autumn 50
competitors from 17 countries took part
the first world champion comes from the
birthplace of flyboarding France
back at Lake Garda beginner Christian
demo is already getting the hang of
things
he enjoys the heady heights and he can
already pull off the dolphin dive pretty
well for the onlookers on dry ground
it's already got superhero qualities is
it something that looks a bit like
science fiction doesn't it beforehand
the other one the first one has jumped
like that like a dolphin we've been
thinking a lot about it but it's a great
new sport why not it's Natur annoy your
spot odd varnish to govern eat us if
this I don't think it will really take
off as a transport because it doesn't
appeal to a wide public onion it's
relatively difficult to buy the
equipment and to store it you meetin
that you have to rent it babe and
flyboarding really isn't cheap a taster
course on Lake Garda will set you back
around 160 euros for water sports fan
Christian Demel that was money well
spent this is Fanson it's crazy it's a
bit frightening when you're up that high
but if you start to fall you can slow
yourself down but of course it's tiring
because you're so tensed up what am I
feeling for comfort time for the
professional to show what he can do
again coach Marco amico flyboarding
superhero
you